- During the Winter School,
it'll be a series of different sessions.
Some of them will be plenary talks
speaking about different aspects
of the science of consciousness.
But there'll also be some social events
so you get to interact
with leading researchers.
Leading consciousness researchers.
- It's a unique opportunity
for young scientists
to get engaged with people
they've read their papers of.
We've all had this
experience as scientists
of actually meeting for the first time
one of the people we admire
or one of the people we just agree with
or one of the people
who influenced our work.
- People get divided into teams
that become these little communities
and they get to work on projects.
And they have a lot of time
outside of just lecture time
to interact both socially
and scientifically.
And I think that really builds
relationships that last.
- And at the end of it, I
think you'll come away equipped
with a whole lot of skills and experience
that will be really valuable
in your academic career
or in fact in whatever
you want to be next.
(bright music)